President Trump is in Vietnam this
morning for an asia-pacific summit it's
still unclear if he will meet with
russian president president rather
Vladimir Putin the White House says
nothing is scheduled but an informal
encounter is in their words possible and
likely early this morning the president
told other APEC nations their trade
practices have hurt the US and fairly
major Garrett is traveling with the
president he's in Danang Vietnam the
site of the APEC summit major good
morning good morning the big question
here is will president Trump have a
formal sit-down meeting with Russian
President Vladimir Putin now the
Russians are game but so far the answer
is no in part because the US has
demanded serious engagement on some
pretty tough issues Syria Ukraine and oh
by the way Russian election meddling in
2016 now the other big issue here of
course is the global economy and trade
and with that comes the sound and fury
of the president's America first agenda
we are not going to let the United
States be taken advantage of anymore
President Trump came to the annual Asian
economic summit complaining the u.s. was
a frequent victim of global trade abuses
I wish previous administration's in my
country
saw what was happening and did something
about it
I will despite the president's kind
words during his state visit to China
just 24 hours ago
our relationship has already proven to
be a great one he called them and other
nations out for cheating on trade deals
they ignored the rules to gain advantage
over those who followed the rules
causing enormous distortions in commerce
and threatening the foundations of
international trade itself contrary to
the president's claim that past
administration's failed to respond to
such abuses America has filed 124
complaints with the World Trade
Organization more than any other country
the US has been accused of cheating as
well with 143 cases filed against
alleging unfair trade practices also
more than any other country
with the First Lady Melania still in
China visiting pandas and the Great Wall
mr. Trump promised to be more
confrontational with the rival power we
can no longer tolerate these chronic
trade abuses and we will not tolerate
them despite the president's Trump and
Putin for the most part it appears that
the most that will be achieved here is a
casual handshake a couple of words here
and there a very informal encounter very
little that's substantive and beyond
it's worth pointing out that as the
Special Counsel investigation
intensifies in Washington about that
Russian election meddling or
collaboration with the Trump campaign
well that makes diplomatic calculations
here all the more complex allies major
will be on whether or not he does meet
with Vladimir Putin thank you so much
for joining us from Vietnam